there's a very interesting article from
the new york times called trump's legal
defense legal team scrambling to find an
argument
and this article
really puts in focus that there is no
defense here
so far
the strategy has been throw everything
you can at the wall whether it's ketchup
or whatever else you have throw it all
at the wall
and see what sticks you might remember
that at one point when we started
learning about
these documents at mar-a-lago at one
point the argument was
there were no documents there that were
controlled by or taken by trump that was
all planted by the fbi that was one
argument they threw at the wall it
didn't stick so very quickly that
changed too
it wasn't illegal for trump to have
these documents at his house
because trump as the president can
declassify whatever materials he wants
and also
laws governing classified materials
don't even apply to presidents of the
united states well but so hold on a
second were they planted by the fbi or
did he have them but they were
declassified or did he have them and
they were classified but it didn't
matter because he used to be the
president which is it but then we
learned oh the crimes he's being
investigated for
it's not actually relevant whether they
were or were not classified
because of how the laws actually are
around the documents that he had oh well
so forget all of that anyway for that
then none of that matters so then it was
listen
we cooperated
trump cooperated all along trump
returned the documents uh trump stored
the documents behind a lock and key at
mar-a-lago just like he was asked to do
but then we got the affidavit unsealed
and in the affidavit there was nothing
about a lock it just there was just
nothing about a lock the story they kept
telling us we were told put a lock on
that the door and then you'll you'll be
all good the affidavit doesn't say
anything about a lock it was about
concerns as to how they were being
stored but nothing about a lock so then
some of donald trump's advisors have
started to insist well it wasn't trump
who moved and put the documents there
anyway it was the general services
administration so you've got to go and
talk to the general services
administration except the gsa has
completely denied this we didn't we
didn't take any documents we didn't put
any documents in mar-a-lago this has
absolutely nothing to do with us so then
at another point they shifted to obama
did it too
with 30 000 documents not with 300 or
700 or whatever the number is
that's not true and it's also irrelevant
you can't say listen i may have murdered
someone but other murders have been
committed as well so you can't come
after me unfortunately or fortunately
depending on your perspective that's not
the way the legal system works
then they floated and this one is just
so absurd
they floated trump likes to take work
home
uh for a job he no longer has
he's no longer the president of the
united states what does that mean and
then
trump wanted these documents for his
memoirs folks trump doesn't read or
write what are you talking about trump
wanted these for his memoirs so the
reality is very quickly becoming there
is no explanation that makes sense and
trump's
cadre of lawyers some of whom he
reportedly hired just from seeing them
on tv
is having a serious problem now in
figuring out how are we going to
mount a legal defense here they will
mount one how are we going to mount a
coherent legal defense if and or when
donald trump is indeed indicted it's
going to be quite a mess